I never thought sleeping with the fishes
who's gonna end up on my bucket list
where is this how do I book it and can
we go it's off Pemba Island and Tanzania
Helen invented by Mick Elgin burg it's
located right in the middle of a coral
reef for fish lovers this is a fantasy
it looks so beautiful down there but how
does Michelle's room survive in the
ocean the position of the underwater
realm is everything they've moored the
room in the middle of a coral reef coral
reef has an irregular structure so when
the waves collide with it and makes a
water go into a turbulent flow that
turbulence dissipates the energy of the
ocean waves the end result of this is
that the energy from the waves is
dissipated by 97% and the overall height
of the waves is diminished by 84% all
this results in keeping that structure
safe so the room itself just needs to
deal with ocean pressure the underwater
room is built like a inside-out fish
tank instead of keeping water in it
keeps water out that much water exerts a
tremendous amount of pressure and for
that reason this thing has to be really
well engineered the window is a made of
two-and-a-half inch or 6 centimeter
thick toughened glass and the entire
superstructure is made of steel which
makes it strong enough to deal with the
power of the ocean the other benefit of
being in a coral reef that's where the
fish hang out looking out that window
must be spectacular fish from all over
the ocean go there to find food and hang
out and throw parties I don't know what
fish do at coral reefs but that's where
they go